how are we going to deal with this
monster who bombs
mothers and babies
well look okay
that is
there is a simple answer to that which
is that he needs to stop i mean for all
of the debate that we have over what the
west should or shouldn't do one man
decides to fly his planes over another
country and drop bombs one man decides
to launch artillery and missiles
indiscriminately at urban areas
including as we've seen yesterday uh
hitting a hospital in which women are
giving birth um he needs to stop
uh could it have been an accident um
russia this morning saying that it's
fake news
well if if it was an accident and i'm
not sure that it will have been
then they need to be asking themselves
some pretty serious questions about
their tactics because the fact is that
they are launching
artillery and missiles into urban areas
where they know
that targeting is challenging and they
are using weapon systems that are not
precision uh that is a policy choice
that they've made and the west is
watching and russian commanders need to
remember that war crimes are not just
committed by those at the very top of
the russian government they are
committed all the way down the chain of
command by all who are involved and
these atrocities are being watched
they're being catalogued and people will
be held to account
does britain want this uh latest
incident in mario paul to be
investigated as a war crime
yes absolutely there's i mean it is
what you see on your tv screens
is a war crime now clearly there is
evidence to be gathered in which to
prove that it is a war crime and western
countries are working together to make
sure that that evidence is gathered in
the best way so that people can be held
to account but let's be clear what putin
is doing is not a war wage between two
militaries right now he has besieged a
number of ukrainian cities and he's
waged a war against ukrainian civilians
at what point will it be right for the
uk and or other nato countries to
intervene to prevent further war crimes
well this isn't being done as nato but
lots of countries have effectively made
a contribution that will allow the
ukrainians to defend themselves better
and with some success so in the first
wave of military aid that the
international community sent uh there
were from the uk's perspective anti-tank
weapons we've now sent
3615 of those
and there's more to come and they have
been as you've seen in your footage of
burnt out russian armored columns
they've been devastatingly effective
other parts international communities
sent things called stinger
missiles now they are kind of
entry-level anti-aircraft missiles but
they've been very successful the
ukrainian government claimed that 48
helicopters and 44 combat aircraft have
been shot down and so successful have
those stingers been that they forced the
russians to fly their combat missions at
night
and whilst i can't verify the footage
you showed
earlier on
that was a nighttime mission so the next
step is to provide the ukrainians with
an anti-aircraft capability that works
at night uh and as the home as the
defense secretary announced the house of
commons yesterday we are looking at a
capability called the high velocity
missile
which we hope will be able to achieve
that and we're just looking at the
practicalities and feasibility of how we
would deploy that uh to the ukrainians
okay rest assured minister we only uh
show footage on this channel that has
been independently verified um of course
i'm sorry i know you're very good at
doing that thank you um we know that the
ukrainians and
the russians are meeting in turkey to
try to uh come up with some sort of deal
isn't now the time for compromise is now
the time for us to speak to our
ukrainian colleagues and and urge them
to come to some sort of compromise with
russia
but what compromise would you suggest is
acceptable i mean you know
four weeks ago ukraine was a sovereign
country living peacefully without
threatening its neighbors within its own
borders
i don't know that the international
community should be turning around to
president zlensky and say it's time to
reward putin with uh having basically
bullied him out of the donbass uh and to
write off the crimea um if president
zlensky were to choose to do that as the
sovereign leader of ukraine that's the
decision for him but i think he's made
very clear he's unwilling to accept that
and i don't know that the international
community should be willing to trade
away ukrainian sovereignty uh as part of
any negotiation
100 military personnel are going to
poland to help with uh visa applications
how many are going to cali
um will you forgive me that i think your
gallery might still be coming through on
in front of on the speaker could you ask
me your question again kate please i can
i'm sorry about that um 100 military
personnel are going to poland how many
are going to cali
um they're we're not sending any to
calais at the moment uh having had a
conversation with a home office
forgive me we've still got the gallery
coming through quite loudly
can you hear me okay
i can i'm i'm sorry about the technical
issues does it fix tonight i'll push on
so we we're not sending any to kelly i
met with the immigration minister
yesterday and i think their feeling is
that the uh the visa application centers
in northern france
are
centers that they can reinforce
themselves
what they have asked us to do is to
supply manpower into uh poland uh which
is uh the busiest of the visa
application centers by some margin
and so we're just in the process of
making that happen uh and we will help
out in any way we can because i think
you know there's there's effectively two
sides to the uh to what can be done to
bring refugees here more quickly there's
a policy choice around the checks that
that we go through but equally you can
increase the capacity of the pipeline to
process more people more quickly
the mod has made it made the offer to
the home office that we will
lean in to help them with that they've
accepted that offer will supply as many
people as they need in order to be able
to get the highest number of people
processed in the quickest time possible
and then the home secretary has got some
choices which i know she's considering
around how to further change the visa
process uh and what checks might be
necessary within it because i've been
looking at the visa application process
mr pm for the benefit i know that you'll
know what it is but for the benefit of
our viewers
people need to create an account they
need to upload proof of qualifying
family in britain they need to upload
proof of ukraine residency before the
1st of january they need to provide
evidence that they're related to family
in britain or explain why they can't
they need to translate the documents
into english they need to book and
attend an appointment at a center in
poland hungary romania moldova or france
to take biometrics they need a tb
vaccination certificate waived but
applicants are mistakenly being asked
for one anyway and these are people that
are fleeing from war
surely we need to do something about
that
well and i think the home secretary is
very much keeping it under review there
is a um it is a hard job to be home
secretary you know you have to balance
uh on the one hand
um and i accept that people will look at
these tv screens and say that there is
an immediate uh imperative to
uh to wave all this stuff and do it
quicker i know
that she is looking very very carefully
at what bits of policy could reasonably
be changed in order to do that but as i
said there is another way of increasing
the speed at which this is done and
that's the bit that we're involved in uh
we will make sure uh through working
with our colleagues at uk visa
immigration and home office ministers
that
we are providing uh staffing to visa
application centers
around the border of ukraine so that
they have higher capacity and are able
to deal with applications more quickly
which i think you know irrespective of
what policy changes may or may not come
that will make things much better for
those who are leaving ukraine and want
to come to the united kingdom what's
going to happen to military personnel
who have deserted their posts to go to
fight in ukraine
they'll be in an awful lot of trouble
well what is that i mean well they have
they have to be clear and the army has
put out a statement overnight um to
to say this it is illegal for a british
service person to uh or first of all to
go absent without leave in the first
place but to go absent without leave in
order to fight in a foreign war is
simply unacceptable and frankly
risks the united kingdom um being
you know
wrongly claimed by russia to be a
belligerent in this and i think you know
service people who might think that they
are
doing the right thing should reflect
that it is 100 not the correct thing to
be doing and i'd go further and say it's
not just that small very that very small
number of soldiers that have gone awol
um apparently in order to go and fight
in ukraine i would say to the wider
veterans community i know
because i have stood
in the room where you do your
attestation and you accept the unlimited
liability and the service of your
country to stand up for what's right in
the world and that there's a thing deep
inside you as a soldier that makes you
see tv images like the ones you're
showing and makes you want to go and
fight to put things right
but no good comes from british service
people or veterans going to ukraine to
be a part of this the ukrainians have
got a huge amount of uh manpower than
their army ukrainian nation has rallied
to take up arms the role that the west
is playing is to provide them with the
best weaponry that we can so that they
can achieve their aims and we are
supporting every way we can this is not
the time for people to be going there
and more importantly kay as the
ukrainians have made clear once you
cross the border with the with the uh
expectation to fight you're in it for
good so people who think they can go
there do a couple of weeks take some
selfies get some instagram shots and
then come home that is not the way the
ukrainians are viewing the people that
go to fight for them
british people should not be doing it